also tonight while millions of illegal
immigrants simply walk across our
Southern border China's dictator Xi
Jinping is walking all over our
president without any fear or reprisal
from Joe Biden China meddled more than
ever in the midterm elections to boot
and according to NBC News president X
openly threatened Biden at their little
Summit in California boasting about a
plan to attack Taiwan meanwhile another
hot spot Iran is more emboldened than
ever directing its proxy in Yemen to
ramp up attacks on a key international
shipping route and the US warships in
that
region here now with more Fox News
contributor former Secretary of State
and CIA director the only person in
American history to have both of those
roles Mike Pompeo secretary Pompeo thank
you so much for joining us I know the
world under Jo bid to be with you this
thank you thank you sir I know the world
under Joe Biden looks so d dangerous um
to us and there's so many hot spots
around the globe but my fear is that we
are clocking in at about one major
crisis War forign entanglement on
America's doorstep for every year of the
Biden presidency 2021 the chaotic
withdrawal from Afghanistan 2022 Putin
invades Ukraine 2023 we saw what
happened in Israel with Hamas and maybe
in
2024 China says it's just going to go
ahead and quote reunify we know what
that means uh militarily invad
Taiwan uh can you walk us through what
the average americ what the average
American should think about this and
know about
this kellyanne you know the these are
not disconnected offense I think you you
grabbed it exactly correctly by
describing these as sequential and and
folling on from each other uh you can
even go back one further which is the
story you reported on early which is our
our open Southern border the the failure
of America to stand up for the things
that matter our own sovereignty our own
National interest abroad those are the
things that invite the bad guys the
tyrannical leaders at shiing ping the
AOL and Iran to continue to inflict harm
on the United States and our friends and
allies and when when you're in a
position where your allies don't trust
that you'll defend them and your enemies
tell you at a summit that they're going
to take another Nation by force if
that's what's necessary and you do
nothing you fail to deter them you
present an enormous amount of risk to
American people uh not only only here in
this country but any American traveling
abroad as well yes and I think that
February 5th 2021 ended up being such a
prophetic day early on in the Biden
Administration one of the very first
things he did secretary Pompeo as you
know is he took the houthis off the a
very important Terror watch list that
was what 16 days into his presidency
this was his big priority as president
the $6 billion dollars he forked over to
Iran so people are looking at that I
know that you were very very fully
engaged AED on the matter of Iran uh if
we had a Republican president again
perhaps president Trump even uh what do
you think could be done is the damage
too deep and too great H give us a
little bit of optimism in what seems
like a very pessimistic time as goes
Iran the the good news kilan especially
in the Middle East is we can get this
back America has the capacity to do that
we're a a great nation and we have great
friends in the region the first thing we
would do is make clear we're not going
to tell the Israelis no you have to
fight this war on a limited basis we're
going to suggest that you need to be
finished somehow eradicating Hamas we
would tell the Israelis do what you need
to do to protect your own people and we
would encourage and support them to do
that we would then secondly go back to
our friends our G State friends and say
hey look we're going to be with you on
the bad days and the good days and when
you do that you isolate the world's
largest state sponsor of Terror the
Iranians you got it right uh this
Administration tried to make friends
with him they thought there was such a
thing as an Iranian moderate which is
just crazy
and so they D designated the terrorists
in Yemen that we call the houthis they
emboldened Hezbollah provided them more
weapon systems they did all the things
in Iran that threaten the United States
and the nation of Israel we can get it
back we know how to do it you put
pressure on Iran you make friends in the
region and you can keep our young boys
and girls from having to ever go risk
their lives and fight and die in that
place like so many have for so many
years secretary Pompeo when it comes to
the Middle East and what's happening in
Israel you had the role of Secretary of
State what advice would you give to
Anthony blinkin right
now well it's difficult because he is
following the leadership of what was
President Obama now President Biden who
have just a fundamentally different view
of the Middle East they're skeptical
when it comes to Israel they don't they
called the king of the Crown Prince in
Saudi Arabia a pariah uh he allowed
Afghanistan to to go away and get 13
Americans killed th those are tough
things for a secretary of state we don't
have a leader who's prepared to do the
right thing thing to deter these
adversaries so I I would encourage him
to to give President Biden the backbone
that is required to keep America safe
it's absolutely possible for America to
get this back kellyan and since you know
everything in every region secretary
Pompeo I have to ask you about something
else in our remaining moments that was
in the news today the prisoner swap
happening in Venezuela what do you make
of
that so we worked hard in the Trump
Administration to get this fellow taken
off the streets the SK Saab uh we chased
him all around we we got him here he was
supporting Maduro the regime there who's
got a $15 million warrant to get him
back to the United States of America
that's the leader of Venezuela uh I I
don't think this trade made any sense
for the United States of America when
you when you cow toow when you bend a
knee to these authoritarian regimes you
I'm glad we're getting some people back
home but there'll be more Americans
taken hostage there'll be more Americans
wrongfully detained you you can't depase
these folks Kelly and you saw this you
you know it firsthand you have to
demonstrate American power when you do
that you can keep Americans safe and you
don't have to make these terrible trades
like the the Biden Administration has
made now
repeatedly secretary Mike Pompeo thank
you very much for sharing your insights
tonight and certainly for being an
amazing patrion and a great public
servant Merry Christmas thank you sir
well bless you Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Kean hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else